vous savez cette fille vraiment vraiment
vraiment grande qui va dans la même
école que vos tu me demandais si tu
voudrais pas eh ben c'est moi non laisse
tomber c'était rien d'important 16 ans 1
m 85 et demi alors il fait qu'elle
tourna au joli ton survêtement espèce de
yéti est toi tu as dit qu à ma copine de
farida arrêts il faut juste que tu sois
courageuse face à l'adversité
oui j'adore c'est celle qu'il te faut
tuer parfait je trouve ça fou qu'ils
veuillent pas sortir avec moi tu penses
qu'à tout moment un garçon plus grande
toile le mec parfait quoi va entrer par
cette porte
[Musique]
j'y vais aussi
il est vain
non bien sûr que non garçon a passé la
douane ya quoi une heure elle est déjà
en train de marquer son territoire alors
s'appelait pour l'instant la mairie pour
l'instant j'aime beaucoup l'amérique
un de ces jours johnny tu leur fera face
et tu leur diras j'aime chaque
centimètre de mon mètre 85 à l'eau
bonsoir je suis l'étudiant étranger ton
école j'espérais que tu voudrais venir
avec mon bal de la rentrée oui oui bien
sûr je vais voir les choses en face et
la géante
j'aimerais juste que tu te sens non pas
à chaque fois que tu essaies de me faire
sentir normal finit toujours par me
sentir encore plus différente
j'ai besoin de ton dieu j'y crois pas
j'ai attendu que ce jour arrive toute ma
vie je vais te transformer de fond en
comble alors mettons-nous au travail que
vous dites c'est qu'à rouge à lèvres et
un gloss ces deux choses différentes
arrête de se presser
je ressemble au canapé de mamie ou à une
sublime princesse sirène
voilà ça c'est moi la nouvelle jeudi me
plaît je dis qu'ils affrontent sépare
jeudi qui obtient ce qu'elle veut je
suis amoureux de cette fille depuis
l'école élémentaire et voilà qui a un
nouveau qui arrive et une rune cédant de
stratégie
[Musique]
tu es en train de draguer mon mec c'est
pas vrai ne t'approche pas de lui la
tour arrêté d'accord avec tout ce que je
dis ok on a tous quelque chose qu'on
aimerait pouvoir changer chez soi tu es
ma très grande petite ça c'est moi tout
ce qu'on peut faire c'est décider de la
façon dont on fait avec
quand tu es une grande fille c'est
vraiment la seule chose que les gens
voient c'est pas la seule chose que je
vois
j'y fais en sorte que tu sois pas blessé